President Biden is heralding the latest
economic numbers as proof that the
nation's economy is stronger than some
reports suggests the U.S added 315 000
new jobs for the month of August that is
down significantly from the red hot Pace
in July the unemployment rate also
ticked up to 3.7 percent last month the
Biden Administration says that's a sign
that more Americans are entering the
labor market and looking for work the
jobs numbers come as more reaction pours
in following the president's Primetime
speech where he warned democracy is
under attack Christina raffini is at the
White House with the latest Christina
good morning
good morning President Biden did address
those economic numbers at the top of an
event yesterday he said they are proof
that the Great American jobs machine
continues its comeback but at the end of
the event the questions reporters
shouted were about that speech he gave
in Philadelphia let's take a listen to
his response
touting the impact of funds from the
American Rescue plan President Biden was
asked to clarify his position following
a fiery speech in Philadelphia anyone
who calls
violence there's 10 violence when it's
used refuses to acknowledge an election
has been won that is a threat to
democracy
democracy
everything we stand for vote vote vote
in his remarks flanked by two uniform
Marines Mr Biden took aim at his
predecessor and his ideology as a
Republican party today is dominated
driven and intimidated
by Donald Trump and the Maggie
Republicans
and that is a threat to this country I'm
very disappointed that the president
would call people who don't agree with
him those kind of names Republicans
criticize the speech for being political
and divisive Senator Tim Scott from
South Carolina tweeted that was a
campaign speech under the guise of a
presidential address this was not a
political speech the White House Friday
defended the remarks as well as the use
of active duty members of the U.S
military and it was about our values as
a country about our democracy and he
believes the men and women who wear the
uniform and protect us every day protect
this country every day that's what they
fight for as well and from democracy to
the economy the bind Administration also
celebrated the release of the latest
jobs report we're not in a recession
period the U.S economy added 315 000
jobs in August but inflation although
slightly improved is still at 8.5
percent so this this is a an overall
good report for the most part when you
look at the at the end of the day here
now some economists say that uptick in
unemployment could actually be a good
thing it means people are less afraid of
covid kids are back in school and
they're able to re-enter the workforce
because remember you're not considered
unemployed unless you're actively
looking for a job but it all could also
be because of inflation and people are
feeling the Crunch and feeling like they
need to go back to work
Christina thank you very much